inside the hospitals of Beijing there is
a crisis unfolding this is the scene in
the Eastern Chao young Hospital the
covert positive largely elderly laid out
the lucky have a bed many do not this is
clearly a place where the virus is
surging and the system is straining
outside there are various signs things
are not all well ambulances come and go
constantly as do wheelchairs of the
unwell
multiple families here told us they've
been desperately trying to get beds for
their relatives this group have finally
been given one
we've been waiting 10 days at least they
tell me almost everyone inside is
elderly and infected
and while official numbers say very few
people have died the reality is clearly
different this cleaner spoke to us while
on a short break and lots of people are
there some people who are dying inside
as well
which is
but despite this restrictions are being
wound down rather than up things such as
rules for foreign arrivals
this had been the welcome for those
Landing from abroad pens of people
buses to hotels and then this the only
contact for multiple days
the response will now also be officially
downgraded meaning a return to such
strict rules very unlikely it is
remarkable how quickly this U-turn has
happened within just three weeks almost
every restriction is now gone but it's
still the case that China has a large
population with low levels of immunity
and a hospital system that is
under-resourced with not enough
intensive care beds it is now under
immense pressure but it seems the
political pressure of persisting felt
worse the economy limping and people
angry
experts say there's now no going back
China has really embraced the entirely
different strategy with gusto is the
same zero that the pursued zero covet
the criticism of the current approach is
that
the authorities had time to prepare they
could have educated the public we could
have taken more measures including even
offering making available basic fever
reducers and so on a reopened China
without testing and rules is clearly a
relief to many but it's come at a speed
and that's come with a cost Helena Smith
Sky News in Beijing